Luis recibió una tarjeta de regalo
por valor de 25 pesos
de una tienda en línea dedicada
a la venta de música digital y de juegos.
Cada canción cuesta 1 peso
y cada juego cuesta 2 pesos.
Si además él quiere comprar al menos 15
artículos con su tarjeta de regalo.
Escribe un sistema de desigualdades
que representen el problema
e identifica el rango de posibles compras
usando una gráfica.
Bueno, lo primero que vamos a hacer
es definir variables,
así que voy a decir que sea
"m" igual al número de canciones
que puede Luis comprar y bueno,
"m" por música.
Y después voy a tomarme a "g" como mi otra variable
y voy a decir que "g" va a ser igual a...
espera, espera, espera...
de hecho, me gustaría más pensar en dos
variables completamente aleatorias,
así que voy a tomarme...
no sé, lo que se me ocurra...
"s" voy a decir que es el número de canciones
que puede comprar
y voy a decir que "g" es igual
al número de juegos que él puede comprar.
Y lo primero que quiero que veas,
es que yo sé que la suma de "s" más "g", es decir,
del número de canciones más el número de juegos, tiene que ser al menos 15,
esto es lo que nos dice el problema,
él quiere comprar al menos 15 artículos
con su tarjeta de regalo,
por lo tanto, "s" más "g"
tiene que ser mayor o igual que 15,
el número de canciones
más el número de juegos,
tiene que ser mayor o igual que los 15 artículos
que al menos Luis quiere comprar.
Puede ser igual que 15,
porque podemos comprar solamente 15 artículos,
pero también puede ser mayor o igual que 15, es decir, puede ser 16, 17, 18, 19, lo que sea...
Y por otra parte, el problema nos dice que
Luis puede gastar hasta 25 pesos
que era lo que tenía la tarjeta de regalo
y que cada canción cuesta 1 peso
y que cada juego cuesta 2 pesos.
¿Cómo podemos escribir una
desigualdad con esto?
Bueno, vamos a escribir primero
lo que está gastando Luis,
lo que gasta Luis es la cantidad
de canciones que él va a comprar por 1,
porque 1 peso vale
cada una de estas canciones,
más 2 veces la cantidad de juegos que él va a comprar  y este 2 sale porque cada uno de los juegos vale 2 pesos,
así que si por ejemplo nosotros tenemos que Luis compra 5 juegos y 4 canciones,
entonces tendríamos 2 por 5 = 10 más 4,
son 14 pesos, él gastaría 14 pesos.
Y bueno, estoy omitiendo
el 1 a lado de la "s"
porque recuerda que multiplicar por 1 es dejar las cosas tal cual, aunque cada canción vale 1 peso.
Y bueno, lo que gasta,
tiene que ser menor o igual que 25 pesos.
Él puede gastar 25 pesos, pero no se puede pasar de 25 pesos porque es lo que tiene en su tarjeta de regalo.
Y ya que tenemos este sistema de desigualdades,
ahora vamos a graficar este sistema de desigualdades,
así que para esto déjame aquí
graficar dos ejes
y ahorita vamos a tomar la decisión
de quien está en cada uno de los ejes.
Y por cierto,
solamente voy a graficar el primer cuadrante,
es decir, donde "s" y "g" son positivos,
éste va a ser el eje de las "s",
éste va a ser el eje de las "g",
porque solamente tiene sentido comprar
un número de juegos y de canciones positivos.
Y bueno, para graficar este par de desigualdades,
lo primero que me tengo que fijar
es en las líneas límite o dicho de otra manera,
en los bordes.
Y para esto lo que voy a hacer
es escribir estas desigualdades
en su forma pendiente ordenada al origen
y para esto voy a despejar a mi variable "s".
De la primera tengo que "s" es mayor o igual que "-g" más 15...
"-g" más 15.
Y bueno, de la segunda tengo....
y.. mejor déjame ponerlo con color magenta...
De la segunda voy a tener si despejo a "s",
que "s" va a ser menor o igual que "-2g" más 25,
"s" va a ser menor o igual
que "-2g" más 25.
Y bueno, esto lo estoy haciendo porque yo puedo asociar una ecuación de la recta
a cada una de estas desigualdades para encontrar mi borde, mi frontera de esta desigualdad.
Así que empecemos con la primera,
si de ésta yo tomo una ecuación de la recta
asociada a esta misma desigualdad,
¿qué me voy a encontrar?
Bueno,
que "s" va a ser igual a "-g" más 15...
"s" va a ser igual a "-g" más 15.
Y ¿qué pasa con esta recta?
Si te das cuenta,
corta al eje de las "s" en el valor de 15,
entonces aquí tenemos el 5, el 10, el 15
y por aquí pasa mi recta
y después si yo quisiera hacer
"s" igual a 0,
entonces obtendría que "-g" más 15
es igual a 0 y si de aquí despejo a "g",
me quedaría que "g" es igual a 15...
"g" es igual a 15
y por lo tanto corta al eje de las "g"
también en el valor de 15.
Así que vamos a ponerlo por acá,
aquí voy a tener el valor de 5, por aquí...
por aquí me voy a tomar el valor de 10,
aquí el de 15 y por aquí también pasa mi recta.
Y ahora, si uno los dos puntos
y como tengo un mayor o igual,
puedo dibujar una recta sólida, es decir,
en lugar de una recta punteada,
voy a dibujar una recta sólida porque
todo esto también es parte de mi solución.
Y si te das cuenta lo que tengo es, "s" más "g"
mayor o igual que 15 en la desigualdad original,
por lo tanto me voy a fijar en todo
lo que está arriba de esta recta...
todo lo que está arriba de esta recta,
cumple esta desigualdad,
cualquier punto cuyas coordenadas sean de la forma "g", "s" que cumpla esta desigualdad,
tiene que tocar o esta línea recta  o tiene que estar arriba de esta recta, de mi frontera.
Por lo tanto,
déjame colorearlo también de verde,
todo lo que esté arriba de esta recta,
va a cumplir esta desigualdad.
Y tú lo puedes verificar, por ejemplo,
si tomamos el 0, 0
el 0 más 0 pues eso no va a ser mayor o igual que 15,
por lo tanto no lo cumple,
no está en esta parte y si tomamos un punto aquí,
por ejemplo el 15, 15, 15 más 15 es 30,
lo cual es mayor o igual que 15,
por lo tanto sí cumple esta desigualdad.
Y si te das cuenta
son todos estos puntos de aquí.
Ahora vamos a fijarnos qué es lo que tenemos
con nuestra segunda desigualdad.
Si nosotros buscamos el límite o la frontera,
tendríamos que "s" es igual a "-2g" más 25
y de igual manera,
si "g" vale 0, entonces "s" vale 25,
así que aquí vamos a tener el 20,
aquí el 25 y por aquí, justo por aquí, pasa mi recta.
Ahora, por otra parte,
si "s" vale 0 entonces
me va a quedar que 0 es igual a "-2g" más 25
y si yo paso este del otro lado sumando,
me queda que "2g" es igual a 25
y de aquí dividiendo entre 2 me queda que
"g" es igual a 25 entre 2, lo cual es 12.5...
12.5 ó 2 enteros 1/2, y eso está como por aquí, cortamos al eje de las "g", justo aquí...
aquí tenemos al 12.5...
bueno, creo que no...
de hecho creo que es justo a la mitad...
ésta sería mi mitad y justo por aquí pasa mi frontera.
Y si te das cuenta, mi frontera también es
sólida porque tenemos un menor o igual,
por lo tanto, vamos a dibujar aquí mi frontera...
ya tengo mi frontera o mi borde
de todo el conjunto-solución,
de esta desigualdad...
y ahora date cuenta que tenemos en esta desigualdad "s" menor o igual que "-2g" más 25,
en la desigualdad original teníamos que
"s" más "2g" es menor o igual que 25,
por lo tanto
todos los que están aquí abajo...
todos los que están abajo de esta frontera,
son parte de mi solución.
Y de igual manera tú lo puedes verificar,
si tomamos por ejemplo,
un punto adentro y un punto afuera,
vamos a ver qué es lo que sucede,
el 0, 0 esto claro que se cumple porque 0
es menor o igual que 25 y si tomamos ahora el 15, 15...
15 más 2 por 15,
es lo mismo que tres veces 15,
lo cual es 45 y 45 no es menor o igual que 25,
por lo tanto estamos bien.
Ahora el conjunto-solución que cumple simultáneamente ambas desigualdades
es donde se traslapan estos dos colores, es decir,
donde tenemos en esta gráfica de aquí,
una combinación de los dos colores,
del verde y del magenta...
y si te das cuenta,
es justo esta parte de aquí.
Esta parte de aquí es donde se traslapan
estos dos colores y no solamente esta parte,
también las fronteras, porque en ambas desigualdades son desigualdades amplias,
por lo tanto también tocamos
estos bordes de aquí y más aún,
ya podemos concluir en este problema,
que cualquier combinación de canciones y de juegos
que tomemos en esta región de aquí va a cumplir
ambas desigualdades simultáneamente.